[Music]
we are F we're located in North Indiana
about 5 hours from here an hour and half
Chicago um we've lived there for about
almost five years now so that's where
we're
at and as said our topic is
improving SE production you can see some
pictures of our family we do have two
young children S three that help us out
and also add some
challenges and you can just see some
pictures of our property there well we
we grow about a quarter acre of garlic
seed right now and we we are looking to
double triple that um I work fulltime
off the farm and J kind of runs the farm
basically and so uh we just want to
share a little bit of our experience and
then talk really about the specifics of
our production system
yeah no
that's so I grew up working at King
green houses starting at age 12 working
there through college so that was the
beginning of my farming experience that
was all conventional but everything from
you know transplanting to retail in that
business um I grew up in Maine and ended
up in the Midwest and so I grew up a
city k
and now uh went on to manage a couple
Farms um just small scale vegetable
production Apprentice on caretaker farm
you may have heard of that in
Massachusetts I believe it's the second
oldest organic farm about 150 200 member
PSA went on to Iowa to start a small
farm to Port Julie um see if we were
right for each other while
farming and um then B and I together
went on to Victory acres and Upland
Indiana down down by m and took a small
farm from about 20 csas members to about
12550 we had two houses chick so we've
kind of done it all in a lot of
different ways and now we're at our
current location living a small farm
dream and garlic is hopefully a key part
of
that so another part of our farm is a
winter produce program we just started
that this past season we buil the hoop
house last summer did um just a 7 we CSA
through the hoop house pick up at the
farm Dan to delivery by his office about
half hour away and that was really
successful we ended up with a reading
list by hand of the season and also
requests for more vegetables all the
time people saying you know my kids only
eat your lettuce Your Spinach so that's
great and we're planning on doing
another trial um we just started ping
and we're hoping
so in terms of our specific garlic cart
production um we were looking for a cart
um with organic hardnet garlic we have
to plant by hand because if you go non
caret garlic it has to be oriented a
certain way otherwise the neck gets bent
and people don't want to buy that so um
there's yet to be a machine that can do
that efficiently um and so we were
looking to scale up for tion that could
do that for us um and also ease some of
the labor fatigue that goes into
planting molting those sorts of things
um also in terms of looking towards
sustainability trying to find a A system
that we didn't have to till as much we
as vegetable farmers are are guilty of
probably over tilling so we're trying to
move away from that especially in our
really sandy soils low organic matter uh
we need to really um work on that so
that was kind of one of our goals we
were kind of hoping the cart would help
us multra straw and Aid in harvesting as
well um one of the products we have so
far is a review of carts available so
this is a 34 page document that's
available on the s website that kind of
um part of our grant was working with
Purdue University so their a engineering
department and a couple students that
came up to the farm kind of figured out
what we needed and it was their job to
see what was out there
and see if um if they could come up with
a better system um something that wasn't
commercially available so I'm not I can
weld but I'm not a great welder so this
was a great opportunity to partner and
maybe come up with something today so
that document is available so if you're
thinking about ways to increase your um
comfort level whether you have
strawberries or any sort of crop it's a
you really useful
document so just to give you an idea of
what prodction system actually looks
like as we think about what kind of kind
machine do we want to help us on our so
you can see this a picture field that's
in October but we're going to start
looking at midly so we SC pasture and we
spread on field and then first part
that's when we do the cover so we
brought a broadcast for the cover you
can see we oats spring radish and we
like disc that that's the beginning of
August then month later in
October
trop strips creat beds and then St BS
Fin and add
am and then
October garlic and this is specifically
what we're looking at the cart for this
is where we are doing everything by hand
and placing each bold to the ground
after we've done that you know you're
hovering it all back up and mulching it
and you can see you from the position
there that it gets to be a little bit
uncomfortable um then we have the 9 mons
[Music]
where
and early to mid July you also dri
irrigation for the water of the garlic
um and then July we Harvest and cure so
that's the Bas production system we're
looking
at we'll take questions at the end just
because we do have a short amount of
time so here some more pictures of us
planting so we have these little buckets
around our waist
to where we need to go and then um
here's another picture just again trying
to adjust your back so that
you you have least amount tension at the
end of the day so that's how we
currently do our
system a lot of hands and knees work
which you know over quarter acre that
doesn't sound like a lot but try doing
that for four days straight really kind
of adds
up wear and tear on the
body so part of the grant was to kind of
look at okay where do we really spend a
lot of our time um and where can we
maximize the use of equipment if we're
going to spend money on it how are we
going to use that efficiently so one of
the things we did is looked at our
system and timed it out okay where are
we spending our time and if you add it
all up planting harvesting and molting
is where we are spending 60% of our time
and so um and then we also kind of
looked at okay what's the most
physically hard um actually harvesting
and hanging it we spend a lot of time
there but that's actually somewhat not
leisurely but it's it's more upright
work and and it's can kind of be done in
different stages so we kind of looked at
planting as kind of the big one that we
were trying to trying to
address so how do we eliminate back
bending awkward positions um how do we
eliminate unnecessary tillage so this
cart's going to be have have to be able
to drive through this pretty um heavy
cover crop and we'll show you some
pictures here and then of course related
to that in our Sandy soils you know we
have about about 18 hot soil it's all
yellow so conserving that moisture is
really important to us and then what's a
scale appropriate machine for us I'm
just going to walk through real quick
kind of what the student at Purdue found
available options here's a cart you
found um and looking further details
this cart didn't end up working that
well the hand crank broke and couldn't
really move along but maybe it has some
merits uh this is something that's
current exists in the US about
$3,500 um but we didn't know you know
we're not doing strawberries we're doing
Carli could it drive through that type
of heavy biomass we weren't sure uh this
is another cart that's quite a bit more
expensive um you'd have to import it
into the US to find it as far as we
could tell and then here's kind of the
cream of the crop the most ideal cart um
kind like a small tank on Wheels but
again it's it's pretty expensive so if
you had a lot of Acres it might might
work um so here's some of the unique
features yeah that these unique features
of how we do our so we pl we have a tall
living cover crop that's really
important on our farm to build the soil
add those nutrients create
iteration garlic not strawberries as you
saw some of the carts the right height
for the that you're doing uh we need
something that's small medium scale
appropriate we like said we're only
quarter acre we like to you know grow
that but this is not a full time thing
at this point and then also also
something that multitask planting eating
harvesting
muling um and then finally we want
something that can be built on far we a
welding shop like just across the street
from us um you know you import something
and there's mechanical problems this
can't always be fixed right commun so
that us
and yeah and as with most Grant projects
you go into these ideal thinking ideal
goals um and how it ends up is often
very different that that's okay that's
part of why um s does these types of
funding projects you don't have to
necessar accomplish gos all here's a
picture of the tall cover CR um these
are our two boys here and some years
that cover poop can be four feet
depending on you know how the fall goes
um and and it's it really provides
probably 80% of our fertility for our
Gar so this is really important that we
keep this our
Sy here's uh what it looks like I've
mowed the strip where our bed is going
to be we do two rows of garlic per bed
our soils are that PO we can't do it
that any more intensively um and then we
um Roa till strip Roa till and so you
can see this thick mat right here um of
cover crop that is going to have to be
able to be driven over by some sort of
machine if we're
plant so here it is a pulse up with our
drip tape this is after planting um and
here's Julie doing some planting you can
see that we have really a lot of uh
cover crop for garlic area
plant you do that again for
our and we're actually moving towards a
system where we don't Roa till at all
but just deep rip a a row um or a shank
on our tractor um so that we don't get
so at all and so that's kind of we
trying to think through how we
plant so here's uh just our farm all 100
with the shank um RI through you kind of
see that there we do have some video on
our YouTube channel that shows it
specifically we won't take time to play
that today but it is
good so this is what uh the looks like
around mid April um May June that's when
we start getting
thecate which we har and sell or to
friends and then um in July we're
looking for about a third of the plant
round back and then we know it's time to
harvest
yeah uh so the garlic part here's the
actual cart un constructed it's got a
canopy here where a tar can be put and
then it's a lay down design um and we
have you know a place where we can
here's actually a better picture some
some of the students actually driving it
around um and we went through about four
engineering students and two
professors so turnover was really high
um not because the carlet cart is that
difficult but that's just the nature of
working with with um you know University
students so that's something we learned
uh I was hoping to be up to about 3/4
acre garlic production by this time but
the cart never really got done um which
actually turned out to be the best thing
because um maybe family structured time
wi we wer really ready to go
so yeah you had to get an extension
which Sarah was gracious to understand
um and at this point uh you know the
part they're having some trouble with
the design um in terms of how the wheels
actually swivel when it's going down the
road so we're almost there but now it's
got a new student new group of students
work so it is what it
is uh some lessons learn keep it simple
I think we tried to put too many things
into one cart um maybe a couple versions
down the road we could have done that
but I think uh maybe should have
acknowledged that up
front students really wanted to
motor think you can do
it yeah I know
Engineers we found that the review of
the current options was really valuable
that was part of something available to
you
to
that so that was a great part of this
we enough time I mean if you think a
Project's going to take two years leave
two and a half or
three you know this not an Ideal World
don't try to do too much we kind of said
that um and it's about the process we've
really kind of refined our garlic
growing process and really thinking
about mechanizing why we want to do that
valuable
for and then just the concept of working
with students is great um but there are
some limits to that
so it
goes all right uh any questions we got a
couple minutes for questions so anything
else
question yeah so we have a website where
we sell Harden X seed garlic um and then
we also do eating Garlic um and so we do
eating Garlic for about 50 cents a bulb
and then our uh seed goes for about
anywhere from to a pound since we're not
certified organic we can't charge quite
that higher price but that's certainly
where
certified
and customers us you're not charging
enough it cost us about 30 cents of
linear row put to produce the garlic so
we were 50 cents a ball that's pretty
good INE but we we should do it more
questions yeah well fortunately one of
the great things with working with
Purdue is that they had the students
each have a budget so that like the
motor um some of the materials they
didn't have to pay for so we did like a
5050 C share on that so that worked I
mean that that worked out great so we're
about three grand into the project
yeah let's say wants to make
that right and that's where the students
have their final report they'll have
their materials list still
in yeah excellent
question well depending where the
students end up with this I'm thinking
we might just take them the motor off
and pull it with our
pH that might be the
simplest no they they thought about that
but I think the students weren't didn't
know enough or weren't didn't have the
staff to do that and I don't but yeah I
think that's that that's a be
aable yep those those are good points
yeah yeah and in that 34 page document
there's kind of
a an assessment of of do we use electric
why I
not the one
were
seen
okay
yeah
cover um
I want my cover pup to Winter kill
because we're not
gonna we want it to grow as long as
possible and then we Mt sometimes we
melt in the fall sometimes we melt in
the spring and so I don't I can't come
in there with an herbicide to burn it
down and I've planted so I can't till
it's oats radish and uh Canadian field
yeah that we we know we burned through
that really quick
um any other
questions yeah
yeah so we the re part of the reason we
do two rows um to a bed and then our
beds are 36 inches on Center is because
of our soil fertility our soils are so
poor basically Sands um and the way our
cultivating tractor set up that was kind
of the
easiest the cart was then designed for
that um get fourt wide so rle one B
at you consider a cover prop you could
use a
roll
spr the question is H have we considered
using a a roller crier as a cover crop
um yes the problem is Roller crimping um
like tyly winter peas
um it needs to be
flowering um to actually kill it at
crimping
um and likewise the oats would have to
be at drain fill so yeah some something
we could consider um Tim
didn't yeah it it might if it winter
killed but again ripping that narrow
shank through we may not even
need we're we're actually TR to not
touch
yeahp good question that are we growing
more than one type of garlic yes we have
about
seven varieties right now we sell four
we s Ukraine music um German career and
then we have three or four others that
we're working on building for are they
all generally ones that in early
July yeah our some of our um we do like
a porcelain lome
and uh Asiatic those are kind of three
categories our asiatics tend
to be
ready whichs The
Works stra yes a wheat straw um we have
quite a bit of pasture that a guy cuss
for us and so we stre
need to it well we mulch it thick enough
so we don't
have that's that's our goal but yeah if
we do need the weed we are
in yeah I I've um done a little bit of
experiment we do apply a little bit of
nitrogen blood meal because of our sandy
soil so I'm starting to try to cut that
back a little bit more um and you know
we're looking at our soil test we've
only been in the spot for four years so
we haven't
seen am
okay so the question is what benefit
will a c give us in terms of
increase um for right now we don't hire
anyone ver and I um and so the the cart
will enable us just in my thinking
looking at the numbers to double
production and still do
that also you know few years ago had
give back problems to the keep work and
you know those are fixed now but we
don't want that again so that's time
just exactly yeah and our goal is
hopefully someday bearm full time just
we're taking it
slow we're going to do things that are
best for
ourf well um the question was is the
cart used for um I don't think it will
be but right now when we Harvest we're
able to pull the plants um our soil is
so light it's one advantage of um and we
pick it right into a wagon pull by a
truck so it's that's much more
efficient the question was what is your
current bu on a quarter acre um so we do
uh
so garlic
plant but we we plant a BAL every six
inches so our rows are about 250 ft long
and so we have let's just say we had 10
rows so that's
50 that's 2500
5,000
Vols and about probably six 40 to 50% of
that is actual marketable seed garlic in
terms of size grade and then the rest
are that's typically what we found that
varies by
variety but that's
a questions
haven't
seen years ago when
had F yes we do foler feed um hous
particularly because inanity soil
housing one of the first things to Le
out um and so we I do a little fish
fertilizer I spray
every during the month of end of April
through
May we found that that makes a
difference we business cards if anyone
wants for contact information
website and a Facebook page and you know
glad to take questions and always
willing to learn and grow from other
people trying to grow
garlic in
October uh we do pre-sales we let our
you know our customers know in June and
then they pre-order and it goes really
fast so that's why we will be uper
numbers you like to move into
restaurants and grocery stores
to thank
Sarah yeah
[Applause]
[Music]